it's New Years Eve oh that's quiet
always lost police contributions all
this lost moment of the year very end
and then we're about to break into the
finale of the beginning of January well
you know I mean January is technically
still winters it's still something of a
finale this is true the cliffhanger
ending two viewers up jib on a new
strong Year's Eve I don't imagine we're
gonna get blown up with viewers today
we're gonna get blown by Furies today
we're gonna get so much BJ's from the
viewers today when did you poll there
what is your favorite what is it ya know
it does Oh take your mantra their
comments in there yeah and I can tweet
it so that our friends know where we are
Michael a you read the description box
low could be whoa we already got lowers
risk for showing up Brendan ready a
Jimmy Neutron double oh my homeboys
right now guys listen normally you're
not supposed to talk about pre-planned
stages for anything you're working on
and until anything's like finalized but
for you early guys let you guys know
that yeah anything you guys donate this
is all it's primarily like pretty much
all who are we going to helping fund the
short films and sketches that we plan on
doing I've been writing a lot lately
we're gonna start off with like once a
month and then we're gonna just don't ed
serious about that this time yeah making
it go by at least by the end of every
month we'll be doing it well Jimmy
Neutron double O thanks for donating my
friend Jimmy Neutron
way better than Dexter's Laboratory no
but it's nice it is yes there's way
better
no and Brendan V dude 15 bars you know
it's not a 35 but it's still cool still
cute still keep nagging
generosity neg generosity that's the way
you're supposed to roll her out here
who's Ryan okay well we got a lot of
people joining in here we got 20 viewers
that's pretty cool like people are on
YouTube oh man a few we're keeping this
primarily towards you now guys because
whoa they're throwing in more bars one
number one fan Bradley 1209 a thank you
my friend
thank you trust me you're gonna like the
sketches we have in mind and everyone we
got Oh John got your notepad so we can
like write down everyone who donates
make sure they get credit
I got Brendan V and I got Jimmy Neutron
you know Brendan be Jimmy and you're
trying to rein the man oh good good boy
anyone doing it's a hundred bars or more
will be thrown in to the special thank
you a chance cook really appreciated dog
you guys rained the mayor rare them a
rare the man their chance cook he's
constantly taking a chance we get
Christopher be a hundred bar okay
Christopher B I'm getting a special
thank you with in our next sketch we're
going we're getting Happy New Year's
from Sweden it'll Salvador over on
YouTube that's great that's fantastic
alright guys so let's kick this off we
gotta end this that's California time
right now is 5:50 p.m. we got to end
this no later than 6:30 3:00 p.m. all
right yes I gotta go to like three
different New Year's events tonight and
I'm hoping to make them all let's uh
here we go
thank you guys for everyone Bradley
thank you for donating my friend so kind
to you Bradley Bradley Cooper is one of
the biggest fans of the real rejects
what inspired him to take on the role of
American sniper and here he is today
steep-ass t-fal okay happy New Year to
you too all right all right so we want
to talk about our top 10 most
anticipated movies of the year 2017 27
now we're gonna hop around when I go for
number five to number three to number
set yeah we would
we do these are just warm-up jokes for
latex or when the good jokes start
happening either just warm-up jokes you
just gotta start you know you gotta get
in the feel yeah yeah just wait - you're
gonna make a good joke sometimes you got
to make some bad jokes so you make a
good ride the momentum I don't let there
be no Julie what do you think actors get
multiple tasty don't just do a great the
first time Christopher whoa donating the
bars my friend Brenda throw it in more
bars well you guys are making it
difficult for us to get to our live
studio thank you Brendon and Thank You
Christopher
wow that is so kinda you're making the
New Year to that much brighter you guys
with your beautiful Christian names
Thank You Brenda me and Christopher
warned us warned us alright alright
alright alright
and yes you know it'd be kind of cool or
anyone who donates we should get the
shout out in the next like this you get
shout outs in the next reaction yeah you
cool perfective anybody doing it's a
thousand bars or more oh that's how we
should do it a thousand bars or more
then you get a shout out and ships in
the sketch anyone donates more than a
hundred bars will get a shout out in the
next in like the next reaction we film
yeah this to be smart this is why I know
whose shadow help okay Christopher V
you're definitely in the short film all
right so let's kick this list off Thank
You Christopher a bit 'bageena our
number 10 choice John and I look through
every movie that's coming out in 2017 we
narrowed this down to a list that both
him and I can mutually agree on yeah and
I think you guys will be appreciative of
it as well now that we have a list of
some films that we know people are gonna
be like why isn't this on our list just
letting you guys know Justice League's
not on here
forget it there are only 10 by 10 spots
were a lot of [ __ ] movies that were
11 spots maybe there are number 10 is
guardians of the galaxy guardians you
gardeners of the galaxy we chose this
one because it just feels like a
for-sure kind of hit it would not just
in terms of box office but I mean in
terms of like its most likely gonna be a
good
it's most likely gonna be fun and it's
we already I'm excited to see how they
can enhance it more because you know in
the first guardians of the galaxy Marvel
I feel as much as they play it safe and
in retrospect in terms of like they're a
beat sheet for some other movies I feel
like they still take Gamble's like take
they take calculated risks they exactly
calculate a risk good terminology their
job it's kind of like you know I got
look at Doctor Strange and I'm like
typical Marvel beaching in terms of
origin tale but it's still risky in
terms of the hero they chose to portray
and this the mood of care do they chose
to introduce next yeah what and it does
britainís serve a sort of like you know
Eastern mythology two things the more
metaphysical presence and China money
gotta get the money it is a piece of
very troublesome debate with that movie
that is you know a topic for another
live streaming video but yeah guardians
of the accident means one of those just
you know as a movie goer there's so many
franchises around and I hear guardians
of the galaxy too and I'm like oh yeah I
like that movie I think I want to see
this one so like I'm I'm happy to see
these characters come back I like the
first guardians it's one of my more
favorite things in the Marvel yeah right
I think guardians is one of those those
rare movies where you really want a
sequel not just because you're gonna get
one but it would bum me out if I was
like they're not making a part - that's
too bad yeah yeah and and I like I like
for the most part you know and I'm happy
to see the the rise that he's got
because he came you know from trauma and
and you know he managed to bring
something new tomorrow for me so I'm
excited and especially some of the stuff
he said about like yeah I know we didn't
have the most impactful villain but you
know we're addressing that this time
like he's talked about it in such a way
that I'm curious to see if they can pull
it off
yeah and I'm also just excited that it's
coming back you know yeah a ball of some
franchises to keep up with this is one
that I actually kind of care to keep up
exactly you can watch our trailer
reviews and all that [ __ ] for that one
let's see okay every every number we'll
take a quick look at the comments
Christopher donates 1,600 bars
- firma homie man I have a cousin named
Christopher and he is no Christ like you
my friend Brendan V keeps throwing them
bars in chants wow you guys are so kind
so kind so oh man I mean we don't have
as made as much time to take as many
questions but you know of course the
guys to donate bars ask a question we
might be able to throw that in there hey
what do you guys think yeah listen to
chances question what do you guys think
will be our number one pick I've made it
pretty apparent in a lot of videos of
what I said well be your number one it
could be and it could be it can even be
Mac's song I guess yeah next to our
number 9 choice is a film um I'm not
100% about but I know I gotta watch it
it's one of those things it's like yeah
I can't say oh I know for sure this is
gonna be a damn good movie I or I would
be very surprised if it's not a great
film but it's something where I'm like I
I just gotta watch it I know I have to
watch it opening night that's alien
covenant yeah yeah yeah at least joke
weekend yeah I don't know if I'd be like
beating down the door to be like it's
Friday Thursday nights god I see alien
covenant is something to me that's
interesting because I'm still kind of
excited that Ridley Scott is in this you
know atmosphere doing you know big
sci-fi again and that's cool and again
it's like ah I liked stuff about
Prometheus enough and I like alien
enough that I am sort of cautiously
optimistic about giving him a second
chance with this yeah this is like I saw
that trailer and I'm like I don't know
if it's actually gonna be like a good
movie I'm a little afraid it's not just
because of some of the things that have
happened with these kinds of movies
lately and all the news is always
changing but all of this stuff makes me
very very curious about it and seeing
that footage makes me very curious about
it so well what
one thing that I think that was kind of
cool about the Prometheus experiment I
think it's rare where you get a film
that still really talked about or really
debated upon and it seems like the
majority of people were kind of
disappointed in Prometheus case the
circles I run into maybe that's just
because I attract Who I am or something
but I feel like a universal opinion and
on line two is you know it is a letdown
but it got everyone talking everyone
start debating and it was it became more
than an alien movie at that point yeah
you know because people really debated
that film whether it was just oh it was
just a bad movie thanks Brendan be for
more blahblah bars competition is
continuing Brendan be a second place on
the right there whatever they say
but prometheus is I forgot how their
proper no Brendan not Brendan be
Prometheus was the film that was highly
debated highly talked about it a bunch
of different scales whether you're
arguing what the whole point of it was
where people are like no there are
answers in there no there's not or
whatever it is it it's cool when you see
an original film I mean even though it's
not entirely original because was going
out the alien verse yeah it's still
really cool to be like you know I feel
like people will talk about this movie
definitely talk about and just a weekend
opener and then you're gonna get over it
I feel like people will talk about this
movie yeah and now I just want to know
what the tones gonna sound like how
enthusiastic how how you know device if
it might be yeah because the thing that
does work for this about that about all
this sort of like it's not alien and now
it's very much alien and I feel like in
a weird way as as frustrated as some
people might be about that it's still
left turn so you're like well I gotta
see it now oh yeah yeah it's different
enough but now I gotta check it out you
know so it's a contentious part of this
list but but yeah I'm definitely gonna
go look at it I hope they continue to
make more alien prequels strawberry
lemon 2 3 4 8
I feel like alien prequels are the
secret ingredient to Hollywood success
that's really what's gonna make ghoulish
Korean films happy new year oh yeah this
video is also to say
happy because number one no we made and
we didn't yes happy we were doing at I
was looking at the analytics and
according to that we ended 2015 with
about three hundred nineteen thousand
subs
this year we're ending with four hundred
fifty five thousand subs it's a hundred
thirty thousand plus more than we had
last year so really appreciate all the
love you guys have given you guys are so
[ __ ] kind this year went by pretty
fast a lot [ __ ] happen on and off the
internet is so one hell of a [ __ ]
year year so thank you guys all you guys
who are joining in right now and talking
with us and you're probably a family or
at some party so I appreciate all you
guys guys and chit-chatting with us
hearing us do this live stream so let's
move on story back to the number eight
Phil number hey cuz we got two innocent
33 minutes it also happens to be a
number eight Star Wars Episode eight the
force that Johnson expands the Johnson
expand
you could make some high-caliber porn
parody yeah I'm saying like I think you
would take the script really seriously I
think you could be the guy who can
bridge the gap between a bad porn movie
with the CIA and a good porn movie the
story you see I I have I always felt
that the force awakens was supposed to
be more simple I felt like they had to
play it safe and they did and I got a
lot of comparisons to a new hope but I
kind of feel like that is just like the
first part of their magic trick idiots
to make it seem like yeah this is
familiar this is a similar you know but
they kept teasing things that would be
more revealed in later installments or
things that are much bigger more
secretive that and a lot of questions
they implant it in there like the
overall main scope was you know a
comparable plotline to a new hope but I
thought there was plenty in there that
makes you go I gotta find out about this
I gotta find out about this and that
that ending the building of Luke
Skywalker for so long and then you
finally see him at the end yeah there's
no dialogue it's like you just want to
you didn't know I want to see Luke in
like several [ __ ] scenes it feels
like somebody got to make a movie again
you know like it didn't feel like
somebody got to make an installment of
something it felt like somebody got to
make a movie and so like yeah it seemed
look at that like it does get you
excited and it does like for me for not
being a huge Star Wars fan
it got me at least hooked back on to the
series because like yeah when I think
back on last year I do remember that I I
do remember a new uh the force awakens I
do
so yeah Star Wars Episode II I know
precious little about it but I think
Ryan Johnson is a good choice for this
see that's where I here's what I feel
about Ryan Johnson being on board was
seeing how incredibly creative that guy
can be and on top of that like I felt
like releasing rogue one was a really
good idea cuz I thought it really showed
that they're willing to take you know I
mean if you guys haven't seen a rogue oh
I'm sorry but it's like on every [ __ ]
article yeah you know everyone dies and
they didn't even want you in her to die
originally and the first scripts by one
bold and they they're like yeah and they
and they thought they couldn't get away
with it the filmmakers were like I don't
think they'll let us kill everyone off
and then they said the studios were
surprisingly really on board and we're
like yeah it just makes that scene well
that's what intrigues me about these
movies specifically because it seems
like like Disney is willing to make star
like they've made Star Wars a flagship
of some kind of where again seeing the
force awakens and seeing rogue wanted
seeing the choices they've made with
those I'm like it seems like they care
about making good films you know along
with just you know keeping the Machine
going like like Disney is an interesting
kind of sinister machine where it's like
there is so much merchandising and there
is such a big money machine but they
still make a movie at least you know
with Moore's awakens with rogue one I'm
like you're really throwing down on like
some film making here know so well my
point with bringing up of the bold
choices of rogue one I feel like a lot
of that boldness and a lot of the oh
this is going in a different direction
and we're being surprised is really
gonna be unleashed in Episode eight I
feel like Episode eight will be the wine
we're okay
all building so they can [ __ ] flip
everything on us or something
I feel like that's when it's all gonna
take crazy turns that's with I feel like
episode 8 will be that one I don't know
anything about it but I feel like it'll
be it you know that's a good point and I
was I started to think about that a
little bit cuz yeah I wonder now how
much you know if Road one has to spin
off but how much of that they are gonna
incorporate like we gave you the sort of
you know a Star Wars movie with a Star
Wars heart and then we gave you this
darker you know more or more heavy Star
Wars movie that we're gonna split the
difference for it yeah and or something
like that and make you know a blend of
those those tones and so like I'm
curious as to whatever they're gonna
make out of this you know I'm excited
for it yeah I think it deserves great
number eight I feel like it's heart is
in is in the right place and I could
tell that from both of those movies and
and I felt good about that so yeah I'm
excited for an hour how should they
handle Carrie Fisher's death that's for
a later video you guys are outside to
cover that today respect we just wanted
to tune in before the year was over and
give you our list immediately but we got
more donations from Brendan Vee thanks
man thank you thanks all Kyle's in the
channel on YouTube oh that's great mr.
either monastic 4:8 and Wow
wow man it's so cool when you guys
donate honestly it's just as this is
really sure written because John and I
were the reason it took us so long to
like actually get around to doing some
type of livestream where people can do
it it's like when it came to the point
we were like well we have incentive to
actually raise some money and we can
like give back through the you know most
we can do is probably mentioned will
probably mova better incentives down the
road when guys are helping us create a
better channel my helping us raise money
for it so it's crazy to see how you guys
are like just helping you know like we
don't know you guys what you're so
cutting something yeah it trips me out
honestly this is just to be that
generous this is so terrific this
started as a weird operation in a tiny
guest house you know they asked mega
seven from there we've kind of you know
just kind of build that from the bottom
you got big dreams for 2017 and we
want to go through with it I mean we
really want to honor a lot like a lot of
2016 has been us prepping for what we
want to do in 2017 a lot of things we
were like we're gonna add this we're
gonna change this room to do pain
towards the game yeah we're gonna really
Christine my dear my lovely Christine
tipped us a thousand bars or screws my
beautiful Christine L Mak you are
beautiful and Brennan aids in will ever
the first reaction shall you subscribe
to I think we're a good reaction under
there's bad reaction channels and good
reaction channels I think we want to go
so our number seven pics are we got to
keep this moving what is what is your
username Christine let me know so our
number seven choice is the movie split
split after a slide that's why the last
I remember I've been excited for any
project well yeah a lady in the water
like this guy knows this guy you know
six cents I have my dance but you got
the lady in the water you know this
guy's got some yes no split that to me
is one of those smaller films that has a
high concept plot that I feel like one
day I can you know maybe raise enough
money to do a film but it looks so cool
this thing it's not because I've been
listening to a lot of stuff about just
you know in creative processes lately
and I theme I've noticed in what a lot
of people say is that you know the more
limitations you have the more creative
you are and M night Shyamalan is a
filmmaker at least to me who I feel like
does really well when he doesn't have
all the gadgets at his disposal you know
like yeah like I really like his earlier
films and like signs I think is like a
pinnacle of that where there is
effects there is an effects budget now
but I still like that movie and they had
enough gifts a minute who cost like 20
billion oh yeah you're at the time and
it's still like limitations like you get
a bigger budget but a lot of its going
to discount and so I feel like once
science was done it kind of tipped you
know and and the bigger he got the less
engaged I got so you know I liked the
visit you
I thought the visit was like fun and I
was happy to see a movie that felt like
he was having fun again and also you
know twisted like it reminded me of what
I liked about him and I and I really
liked his devil was like to me still it
didn't have the M night Shyamalan Flair
it wasn't yet it wasn't like him doing a
guitar solo or like yeah I feel like
split is him back in comfort like
comfortable and more confident again to
go this is this is like an M night
Shyamalan kind of film yeah the visit
was like let's let's let's try this
thing out and see if people are okay
yeah and now yeah go go nuts man and and
this again it looks like a crazy little
concept and it looks kind of
exploitation II to like it's getting
great reviews - yeah fantastic feedback
and like in the in the damage we're like
you have to just accept spoilers is just
a hazard of your week you know like
something will get spoiled for you this
week probably it's the one thing in
recent memory where everyone's like in
all the discussions and article
headlines it's like don't [ __ ] spoil
it okay yeah we're all agreed don't
spoil this I mean as much as M night
Shyamalan has said in the past he
doesn't want to be knows the twist
ending guy when it's there he doesn't
write its crew yeah but it doesn't ride
it's cool I get it yeah but but hey man
the ones that are greater memorable and
also it's like this is James McAvoy you
know sort of force performance and I
like you just sound like it's gonna be
that with some interesting direction
from M night Shyamalan like this seems
like yeah this is the M night Shyamalan
but I hope we could go back to you know
yeah I'm looking forward to that for
sure you guys looking forward to split
you guys looking forward to split we
should keep this open so we can tell
when people donate you know that's a
great idea it's had a - science twist
everyone else does I didn't mind the
water war of the worlds' think what I
did kind of mine was the baseball thing
oh my premonition
yeah I I'm interested yeah I like signs
in general and I I feel like the twist
lets a lot of people down
not because of what it is but because
it's it's an underwhelming twist for an
M night Shyamalan movie you know like
like six sets hit this thing so well I'm
like you know you think about these
aliens I don't think the story ever
gives you enough to logic out why they
would come a mostly water planet it's
cuz Italy yeah well I think a great
twist is something where it's in front
of you and you could see it yeah you
would have never known but you would
have like never been like hearing his
dying wife Mel Gibson's dying wife
saying swing-away Meryl oh yeah I could
see you now she was talking about when
the anything will become there and have
to beat the alien with his back yeah I
don't know yeah like they're they're
they're moments I want to like about
that plotline and there are things that
I just can't quite yeah yeah science was
I feel like it's just underwhelming cuz
I liked I got it I was like yeah this is
your War of the Worlds it totally good
yeah so I don't know all right let's
move on for number six we got fish this
in 22 minutes
number six enough time for CNN to give
you the world
spider-man homecoming spider-man John
finally saw Captain America Captain
America Civil War and yeah John what did
you think of spider-man I thought yeah I
find come on who did a great job
I thought spider-man was great um yeah I
finally before the end of the year I
finally saw Civil War and I was I was
quite overwhelmed by them as I closed
truth it was cool about it made me
excited too it made me excited to see
spider-man again and that's the one
thing I had problems with about this
movie at all was like you know we've
rebooted the series once and it's hard
to come close to Sam Raimi's first two
movies for me and at least right now I
actually want to see this yeah like I
think it's it looks different enough and
on you know I marvel you know for as
many things as you can say against what
Marvel does they seem to have at least
decent judgment well I feel like they're
really going fully committed to the
concept of it of a team a dude in high
school who has
and what has powers like maybe a year or
something because in civil wars since
that it's really about six months yeah
so I'm like maybe it sound like a year
year-and-a-half now where he has these
powers and it's like yeah he does and
Tom Hall is that kind of guy who just
looks like he's gonna stay that age for
the next few years
yeah risk like oh he's looks too old now
to be in high school because I keep
thinking he really is a 15 year old kid
and you brought this up about how we've
had like three different spider-man's
now in the movies and they all have
brought something different to it and
specifically you know Tom Holland brings
kind of like this anxious nerdy nice guy
vibe yeah like you know he's shy but he
seems like that kind of shy kid who
would make the covered would have the
courage to try to talk you think that's
the guy who you look back on your life
you should have been so much you know
and and that's a thing I'm interested
because you know I Andrew Garfield was
like just wrap that dude was cool he's
really without a [ __ ] he was James Dean
of spider-man and I'm not against that
portrayal but I am excite
this made me excited both to go back to
high school with him and you know just
to see his tapes it got me excited about
a spider-man movie yeah when when I
could easily feel more cynical about it
so and it hasn't because it means it's
my match I come from so like darker or
more toned down by please yeah yeah
because everyone saw the Dark Knight
thought it would work for every [ __ ]
franchise but but this I'm looking at
this style of this latest spider-man
movie it's not going like 100 percent
balls out like how Sam Raimi's felt
really comic-book II this feel it still
feels like a comic book but it does have
its own Flair that's real separate from
the other films which it which I'm glad
to see that is present in the trailer
that one came out at a time it feels
very fortunate to me because Sam Raimi
spider-man still feels authored and it
still feels distinct and and there you
know as they're become more superhero
movies and the trend has sort of taken
hold you know certain things get more
homogenized so you have movies like
x-men and spider-man and
you know Batman or Batman Begins that
feel distinct you know yeah I feel like
they're salut starting to get closer to
that again and that's hearing the
directors say that he wanted to make
spider-man homecoming kind of like a
John Hughes movie is like I feel like
Marvel's finally clean the code at least
a little bit where it's like you got to
make these movies and pitch them to
everybody but we're gonna do is we're
gonna make them for kind of a different
first time ever this John Key has
produced the original star face the
black and white one and he also did that
film with the airplanes they haven't
been home movie about him John a huge
wave but you know it seems like they're
making each of these films for a
slightly different audience and I'm
that's the way to go to me cuz you don't
make the same exact movie each time
movie ladies sarah says she's anxious to
see Logan let's see if that's coming up
on our list soon I don't know and mod er
hey we got some female followers here ah
females ladies to give us her men I
would like for many more ladies to enjoy
our Channel
yeah specifically is really ladies
really any and all really trying to tap
it to the Israel fan base I'm taking a
trip are you down times day ladies who
wants to be my Valentine in Israel I'm
taking a trip for this next one to Rome
because number five is John wick chapter
two yeah sequel to insidious chapter
three yeah John wick chapter two is our
number five choice I'm primarily excited
for this because of how much I loved
it's not necessarily that the trailers
got me super like the trailers I mean
the action looks [ __ ] dynamite still
the action still was like whoa but I
don't know I felt that way about the
John wick one trailers - what this looks
cool yeah this looks really cool but but
it didn't like
captivate me in style and story
as much as the movie itself yeah and I
feel like I have a feeling that they
these if they don't seem like they're at
the level yet where they would [ __ ] that
you know Jean yeah I don't necessarily
want John wick to be like a full-on
movie franchise but I feel like John
wick too could be like the Red Baron
doll it's like it could be here's even
more resources to do your crazy [ __ ] and
maybe then they can wild out on this
movie and I'm down with that idea and
what's cool about it is like it's not
like a transporter film where the
transporter from it's only about Jason
Statham John wick has a whole world to
it and and even the first leg it's it's
about a specific story like yes but I'm
saying that like the world is there like
that they show the Continental look just
style in the vibe of the Hitman the
contract killers are the understanding
the bars are like everything they do is
very uh there's a much bigger playing
field here than just let's watch John
wick story in most scenes in that movie
build the world - yeah exactly exactly
and who does right we will find out more
about John wicks Jason Bourne past yeah
and I wanna meet John McHugh John wick
also seems like a character that like
everybody kind of got behind like all
everybody I know is like yeah John wick
so I feel like it's cool to have a you
know a hero around and it's like you
know action movie it's dark and gritty
but it's cool it's in many a stylized
and like you're not wick is like he
seems like he has the fairest judgment
Yeah right like that's I'm glad we have
a protagonist like that Larry Fishburne
is gonna be in everybody for everyone oh
you know what I saw some passenger you
watched it yeah I saw passengers that
you like it um that's a really
complicated answer to that John got 15
minutes of finishes but no like guys
movie lady Sara says she loves our
channel Oh watching this for a long time
I just like the I love you lady Sarah
Lawrence Fishburne just just shows up in
every sci-fi movie now just to say hey
oh yeah that's right Laurence
Fishburne's in it yeah I was like I
forgot about that so I was like oh this
is just like
it's just with more like forlorn romance
there you go Kyler man collar man's in
the chat kyle Ehrman's in the chat all
right guys
Wow it's looking at these bars is so
amazing please donate drop in we already
have a lot of ideas we're working on
we're gonna put some good [ __ ] together
for you guys in 2017 so thank you guys
or everyone is helping now our number
four choice is Thor Ragnarok Rocky Thor
Ragnarok haven't seen any footage of it
people have only been hinting you know
rumors of what's gonna be in it some
stuff they say is confirmed
you never know that [ __ ] sometimes it's
like I'm give this half the movie news
is people flat-out lie yeah
so thor ragnarok primarily it's the fact
that this directors on board yeah and I
love the idea of primarily seeing a
thorn Hulk movie you know kind of kind
of side by side yeah you know I
obviously put this in the shower earlier
what I really wish they would get a Hulk
standalone movie damn there's a whole
world to the Hulk story and you know
he's got a whole love relationship with
that Betty Ross check whether have
announced Black Widow stuff happening
I'm just like well and I feel like maybe
they're gonna set that up through this
you know enough people like the Hulk
storyline maybe this is a tailor-made
moment for people to go where's the hole
yeah movie and then uh me because if
this is Thor in there and and Bruce
Banner or Hulk in this a lot I feel like
this will be the time when people will
probably Mike there could be a possible
two people walk away being like the Hulk
is real standout film you know yeah and
I feel like this is a cool opportunity
maybe I don't know how big the Hulk's
presence is gonna be Bruce managed
presence is gonna be but it seems like a
cool opportunity for two characters to
help each other out because like the
first door movie I thought was like
pretty good and then the second one I
was like okay and now I'm like I'm
excited for this one because it seems
like now is their time to figure out
Thor to make Thor shine and they have
got an interesting director who's made
mostly indie stuff but who has enough of
a clever edge than like I bet you could
nail this yeah and like that comedy
short they put out like I like what
they're doing
and especially this phase of marble for
the stuff I've seen lately like Doctor
Strange and Civil War and you know their
new slate I feel like they're actually
it seems like they're stepping towards
more come on I didn't stuff I thought
the first Thor was good the Thor the
dark world I didn't hate like everyone
else did everyone hates Thor the dark
world I didn't hate
I feel like Thor the dark world gets
hate just because it's everyone's least
but but I feel like I feel like it's
just the tones of both of those films
can sometimes not quite know what they
want to be if do they want to be this
cool fantasy film or do they want to be
a film that kind of pokes fun at itself
yeah you know and like so camera can
often feel kind of out of place yeah
even those songs it's funny but it's
like it's a little like the first floor
had it down at the right times I felt
but I feel like this one will get part
of the magic too many of Marvel's movies
is its humor especially when the humor
is done very well yeah and I feel like
this director would know how to kind of
balance both something just tells me
that this director would know how to
really bring this to life and maybe not
get so carried away by the the huge
scope he's dealing with you know yeah
and I don't again I don't know much
about this movie I haven't read a lot
and I don't know where the story is
gonna primarily take place but I feel
like this some stuff I love the most
about the first Thor movie and some of
the stuff I really loved about that
short they put out is that what can make
Thor magical free franchises that he's
at least for a while he's always gonna
be a fish out of water on earth and he's
always gonna have something new to learn
about just how to interact with earth
people and that's a great way to harness
that comedy and if you watch like what
we do in the shadows and stuff it's all
about these kind of not quite connected
people trying to connect in society you
know trying to be a part of the world
and that's you know everybody in the
first Thor goes back to the smash
another you know yeah and I feel like he
can bring the right blend of like
adventure but also you know
fish-out-of-water comedy I feel like you
would know how to because part of the
problem with the comedy and thought of
the dark roll was it felt like comedy
wine
yeah what part of the magic I felt about
civil wars Civil War's not filled with
humor but it's fairly spread out like I
know like washing it with you again I
noticed that along the humor came and
rather late like when things started
when you started laughing pretty
consistently yeah comes in much later
into the film and only for like the 20
or 30 minutes segments like right around
the spider-man shows up is when they're
sure they pull any more humor but my
part of the joy of that was that it
sounded like this is what all the
characters say it's not like this is
yeah they would say this is how they
respond is what they do not like Natalie
Portman is showing up and ask are you're
like you didn't think about what that
character's sense if yeah might be like
exactly and I feel like this this
director would have a good grasp on
knowing that next up-and-coming Emsworth
I feel has been wanting to least it's
over Tommy a little bit because the word
you're kind of looking as more of a
serious kind of character yeah but
there's a lot of humor if you had Thor
and I feel and that short film they
released showed me that like I feel like
this film will know how to be a little
bit more aware of what it really is you
know yeah because Thor is it is charming
and boisterous and that's what can make
this more to sink us we have so many
hulking you know we have so many hell
Drogo's out there why not make him a bit
more funny in about I liked yeah hey hey
guys Christopher V god donated the most
he wants to know if fate of the Furious
is gonna be on this list
well we're down to our last two last
three i-93 yeah wrap this up in ten
minutes
all right number three let's see if it's
on or Christopher B is it is it number
three gonna be it's gonna be it's Blade
Runner
20:49 yeah maybe the Furious all right
Blade Runner 2239 I'm going to re-watch
blade right here because I don't
remember like a lot of the end and
because I saw when I was really young I
remember the bad guy gave him like a
speech in the ring Ike I just don't
remember it that well but I do remember
what I do remember about it and before
what I saw not long ago again I saw the
first hour again I remember thinking
like this is fantastic to this day this
is amazing this is amazing stuff
so what's getting me jacked about this
is so many things
one haven't seen Ryan Gosling in a film
like this - I'm glad to see Ryan Gosling
is in the film under the direction of
Dennis vagina Denis or feel new there's
I mean I'm really excited to see what is
when a fan takes over to continue to
pick up this story you know I feel like
he won't just do Blade Runner react I
feel like he'll I feel like he's smart
enough to know we got to add something
like different here yeah I want to put
something my own touch to this and a
human core not just captured Blade
Runner yeah you know yeah this is one of
those guys it's interesting when
directors really take off you know and
you see their names everywhere
especially after they direct you know
you know like an oscar movie or
something like that you know you see a
director blow up sometimes and that's
always an interesting thing to watch
because some of them prove that like
yeah you're gonna just [ __ ] rock out
for the rest of your career and some of
them are like you're gonna go a little
too crazy and then you know you'll still
keep making movies yeah but that
greatness like this guy seems like he's
on a good streak like you have done
different kinds of movies and he always
brings an interesting core to them and
yet anybody's gonna take on Blade Runner
now I feel like he's yeah this would be
the first time he's picking up a
franchise you know first time he's
proving John and I had this belief that
directors in order to be established as
an amazing director you know like oh
this guy definitely knows what they're
doing didn't have at least three solid
great films like three three films that
were like that's our third film great
and he's had prisoners Sicario his enemy
was in between there but not all my
people count that no look I saw his
third movie was a rival though ya know
and rival was like oh he's got a prison
versus a car he knows what he's doing
you know and if he give it if you can
nail this cuz this is you know this is a
known quantity it's franchise being
speak and nailed this I think you could
just probably do whatever he wants from
there on out that's why the reviews for
live by night don't faze me for doing
the Batman
yeah cuz if you had only done like God
Baby Gone and then
by night maybe like maybe he might not
do a good bad man but but Ben Affleck
has had three amazing films come out
what DNA has lived by night which
doesn't like perform as well with people
but I'm like I'm so it's just rule of
three we're talking about now people say
live by that was just like it's not bad
it's just like this is tiny there it's
nothing new from Ben Affleck is yeah
kind of it's fine you know yeah it was
more like a love letter to these films
without really adding something fresh or
original that's what I like people say
that's not actually I'd be interested to
see sometimes cuz it might be pretty
good and also Harrison Ford is one of
the few actors when I hear he's
returning to a role I'm like alright
is he still cool he's still good even
though he doesn't give a [ __ ] there's a
thing about Harrison Ford it's not like
you know like if Arnold's only returning
or Stallone's just returning where I
have these doubts as I'm just like it
makes the lung proof you can still do
the action incredibly well and it can do
the Rocky character incredibly well and
but like Bruce Willis would die hard or
you know like actors revisit these older
roles
Harrison Ford the only time that what's
weird is the only times I think he looks
a little odd is when he's actually like
shooting guns yeah but when he is the
character like just having scenes and
interactions and stuff I think he's
great
yeah Harrison Ford is one of those guys
that each time I see him show up again
he still brings some of that magic
there's a presence he has yeah he's
committed he's he's not a meme he's not
he's not a meme like Arnold or
Christopher Walken or or any or you know
a Gary Busey or any of these guys who
like just pop up and be damned and the
thing is Harrison my include Gary Busey
in there
I think he's just great in Point Break
but but he's one of those guys too every
time he shows up I'm like yeah even as
han Solo
I was like you Patrick cuz I know he's
got that like yeah get paid right every
time he shows up he's conjures up
something for me and so yeah just see
him you know reprising a role and to see
him opposite Ryan Gosling I can't I
can't imagine that magic is not gonna
happen there yeah yeah I met I think
it's gonna be an amazing
so and I would just go based off that
teaser although I would go without the
geezers
like yes here it is behind ya man yes
guys assume it's on a fee of Roger deep
like it's gonna be too much this is
gonna be amazing
but Dennis with John and Roger dick it's
gonna be amazing
hey JB's
he said you guys got me my girlfriend
she is a massive fan and helping you
help break the ice
wow I want to take a picture that that
is an honor I own your yeah nowhere to
go oh that's wonderful movie ladies why
don't work out if we can see blade
rather than those underworld series Todd
no we're ladies crossing over I would
hate that honestly beers don't do that
maybe as a graphic novel I'm just more
sure about that yeah every way more sure
about that like guys even I think this
is too big yeah well so we got two more
to say real quick number two choice is
the fate of a furious crusader Perry
number one donated bars guy it's about
family it's about family it's about
family
let's call get out get out Jordan peels
you move Jordan Peele that that looks
like I mean I'm excited I'm excited to
be excited for a film that is not a
comedy from a guy who I know is known
for comedy and that's like one major
aspect of it because one thing they've
done with a lot of their sketches
especially and even like parts of here
is they they they kinda remind me of
rock or Agra in the sense that they go
to make something funny but when they
have a chance to make it kind of cool
and honor the genre yeah they go for it
yeah these guys clearly have seen a lot
of movies yeah and they know how do you
style for to elicit the reaction usually
it's a laugh but you know they know how
to use style and to shift between and
horror and thriller is an element I feel
they like to play with already yeah
suspense of some format they like to
play with already so watch
the trailer forget out that just looks
like to have all the qualities of a fun
horror movie that could be more than
just a fun horror movie and yeah well
you know yeah it seems to have like
crazy psychological mental imagery seems
to have the paranoia down and I love
like paranoid characters and movies yeah
it seems to have like a big sense of
humor about the world that is that it's
taking place and it certainly looks like
it has a surreal strange quality you
know if nothing else I mean the trailer
is very disconcerting and you know I
mean like I mean they say comedy and
horror are very similar I am so excited
to see his hormone it's because those
are the two genres that have very
specific emotions are trying to elicit
from you live comedy they want you to
laugh or they want you to get scared
and they ride a momentum in a way you
know a laugh and a scream are kind of
similar because they're both kind of
pulled out of you without you're just
deciding to do them you know and so yeah
and so like to see him oscillate more
like I feel like there's got to be humor
but there's gonna they're gonna tip up
the scales on this suspense and the
horror stuff and I can't wait to see
what he does like the trailer looks
bitchin and I'm super excited you know
looks diverse it looks cool it looks
like a horror movie that has you know a
bigger story working underneath it made
me and I that's all the stuff that I
want you know oh yeah sorry we got to
move on now laughs number one it's so
far over that's the first night we have
so far
guys our guy incoming Star Wars Episode
eight split seven spider-man homecomings
John wick Chapter two Thor Ragnarok
Blade Runner Tweety not get out what's
number one
today either I'm kidding it's ghost in
the shell' Scarlett Johansson
it's definitely no gay it is definitely
love you better check yourself
definitely the Logan it's alright fate
okay look we made this list
democratically we agreed upon there's
all the movies that are not on here
Kong Skull Island yeah the belt these
are movies I'm all going to watch but
there's not on this list Kong Skull
Island
the Belko experiment ghost in the shell'
Ville area in the city of a thousand
planets Kingsman the Golden Circle war
for the plan of the Apes saw legacy
Justice League the Belko experiment fate
of the Furious we mentioned twice Logan
I've said it no I've said so much
already throughout videos and other
things about like why Logan is my number
one most anticipated film long story
short it's Hugh Jackman's last outing
he's one of the rare like Red Dead
trailers agha be like excited the for
the fact that like like that was
something that really did appeal to me
the violent aspect of it it just looks
like my kind of movie in terms of I like
those slow burner kind of films I like
the tension films I like the atmosphere
it kind of haunting moods backed with
violence and action that's really cool
with like gritty characters they take
their time when they talk to each other
and scenes you know this looks like one
that's gonna get to be what if whatever
it was yeah last outing its jingle James
Mangold's second passage this like I
feel like there if all goes well it
seems like they're being allowed an
opportunity to do something really cool
with this and I I'm excited to see it
like this is the one like superhero
French
like yes I want to see that soon you
know it just looks really special about
it yeah this it doesn't look like any up
like I'm sure I know we've had graphic
novel adaptations and superheroes who
are not part of like Marvel or DC or
even like you know we've had other
interpretate like vamp blade at one
point we had Watchmen yeah this one's a
little different than other superhero
movies yes I know but to take a
character who pretty much launched what
we have today okay yeah it was the x-men
but let's face it it was really a
Wolverine so it was it was really
Wolverine who like launched it like you
know the Gecko went to him to have his
last outing hearing that Hugh Jackman
took my paint cut because he was like
well to make a better film I had to take
a pay cut so we can actually get this
project done to here they just so
awesome is like yeah I feel like they
got to treat this one with real this is
relevant it seems like exactly it seems
like a passion project yeah as well as a
big blockbuster and I'm like when when
yeah when when a superhero flick is able
to do that I would love to see what
comes out yeah and like to see the
character of Logan in this flux even be
bold enough to go in this direction and
take that take Logan in the little world
work his character will be so unique and
interesting to watch in that specific
time in his life yeah that sounds like a
great great [ __ ] time I have I have
the utmost faith in it and James mango
did 3:10 to Yuma which is an amazing
Western yeah that is a good that is
really good movie a long walk the lines
really get me it's not Western but you
know southern but even zoom yeah but you
know like he's got a show anything a
certain amount of a range and yeah and
3:10 to Yuma is a great indicator and it
also looks like it's gonna have a
certain amount of that comic book like
heightened quality there are a lot of
really striking you know vogue images in
that trailer I really feel like this is
the this isn't like another installment
in the x-men films this isn't like
because even Civil War kind of feels not
the movie itself but just the idea of it
being made
the promotion yeah you could tell there
was a lot of passion and a lot of care
put into civil war but it still is like
what we've still got like a [ __ ] ton of
other marvelous coke you know but this
one they're like this is gonna be his
last movie we're gonna make sure this is
like the heart of war or you go out with
a bang yeah oh I'm just calling Logan
even calling it green cuz you know like
you know what Logan means hey
Christopher you donated more bars Oh
Chris you know another word I learned 4b
is Vikram named the show where I got
that name from if someone gets it down I
want to just see before we go someone
could get down someone could get down
word I got the name Vikram from anyone
know where I got the name Vikram from
yes
Christopher big is from my friends
there's a friend Ross protects to be a
guy named Vic from what he likes [ __ ]
up is like Phoebe and Paula's
relationship at one point oh okay this
is become some people on YouTube were
asking about Dunkirk if there's any love
for Nolan I would put that movie on the
runners up with I guess I'm excited to
see a corner watch it I'm more excited
for the IMAX experience I'm not as
excited in terms of I just really want
to see Dunkirk I'm more excited in terms
of I want us I know he's like shoot this
is the most celebrity use IMAX cameras
and he seems to be the best and using it
yeah it seems like anytime he does it he
makes the eat he like knows what it's
like to go to iMac he knows like how
he's gonna do this and I was gonna give
you an IMAX experience yeah it's not
just oh there's some cool scenes with
the guy next cameras here you know yeah
like it's giving it's been harder than
you know it's part of the movie magic he
brings you know he's the one one of a
few people who uses what you could call
a gimmick in a way where I'm like I feel
like you wanted to make this whole movie
this way but because you can only make
you just took that opportunity yeah
instead of being like oh well we can use
this and we don't need to but we do like
he seems like it really builds it him to
his yeah I mean the DNA and I'm excited
for that somebody else also asked about
the new Halloween movie and if that was
coming out in 2017 I would be so excited
but I have no idea when that's going to
happen so could be I'm really free make
sure just to knows okay guys before we
say Happy New Year and end at this video
I'd say that the one movie think that
should remake is the Godfather Part 2
Freddy got fingered crossover X versus 7
got fingered by the Godfather
I'll be John Green and Marlon Brando Oh
Kyle yes Oh Kyle's smile we're gonna
have to have a like rules only June
I know it's we're gonna add a new group
Zumbi I would 8:00 I'll meet you halfway
maybe don't let him write it but let him
direct it
Christopher V concede any of the most
bars wonder question a Jabba the Hutt
movie absolutely I have so frigging
Luther [ __ ] Han Solo movie I love Rob
Zombie's Halloween [ __ ] Han Solo man I
say yes Jabba the Hutt come from
well of course Louis's rise to power in
the criminal underworld yeah man I
really want to know who this young young
slug was growing up what made him so so
much of a crescent [ __ ] you know like
who this let's cast a great actor let's
get like Ed Asner or somebody to play
Jabba the Hutt really explore this guy's
character why would he enslave no CGI
job
now I'm gonna CGI all practical and you
don't have to do a full monster costume
you know just get like after John
Goodman and complete Java the baby I
mean the problem with that is like a
young Jabba the one hand that's a little
bit mean however I think he would be
tremendous like there are so many people
being like 10 Cloverfield Lane he should
get an Oscar nomination I'm like you
know what yeah he's pretty great he's
legit now he's showing that came out in
March yeah it's the months the calendar
decided calendar decides no Goodman lost
weight
oh that's okay well he could do a little
[ __ ] Jonah Hill on it take it all
together and they could play yes I'm
getting all the way it will be young
your job and
yeah alright guys I gotta end this I
gotta go meet up with my family got a
gtfo let's give a shout out really fast
all the guys who donated birt'day dig a
hundred seventy-five bars you got lines
right I don't think I got burned
Bernardi Oh Bernard you dig you know
what I just a screenshot these guys
chants cooked onion 240 bars Christine
LMK thousand bars one Greg DV 1060 bars
and the most Barb's donated today
Christopher ruinous for 2337 bars oh
yeah all those have been around us I
know everyone's usually broke at this
time of the year including us so thank
you guys for donating today we have a
lot in mind I am actually writing again
and I love it I'm hope you guys will
love more of our creative sides to come
out in the next year happy New Year to
all of you I know YouTube is also
watching this happy new year on YouTube
YouTube is the reason we're here on you
now right now and you now is the reason
world's connected to YouTube isn't that
funny how it all works
everybody the Kyler Minh is beautiful
man
we love Him and Brendan be dipped
another thousand Brendan you just this
is the best part about 2016 receiving
money from you 60 your generosity is
kind so we gained about a hundred thirty
thousand subs this year let's go for
another 10,000 next year's thousand more
subscribe for peace we can do it John I
think we can reach 10,000 more by this
time yeah I think we could do that let's
go for 15 why am low Oh Christopher
Venus wants to be topped why he's into
500 more bars hmm bypass Tyrone I can't
I can't bypass Tyrone we only exist in
this row because Tyra movies at 3,000
bars
whoa oh my god Brett
Ward the board's bar the worlds the
world oh my god you guys are so kind
let me screen shot everyone here I mean
don't they have it don't they have a
thing where they can there's list
adapter right right yeah there's a log
every we can know everyone who donated
for January Happy New Year to you all I
hope you all have a great night I know
some people on different time zones it's
already the New Year so appreciate me in
the future Marni [ __ ] now I saw you
commented to us you're a beautiful girl
one day I'll meet you in London take
care of down streets